هذه هي سيارة فيراري إف 8 سبايدر ،
وهي فيراري إف 8 مع ميزة إضافية
للشمس ،
فإن فيراري إف 8 هي أحدث تطور
في تصميم العلامة التجارية للمحرك المتوسط ذي الثماني أسطوانات ، و
ي تتمتع بكل الإثارة التي تت
قعها من سيارة بقوة 710 حصان بش
حن توربيني V8.  خلف المقاعد ،
يدعي فيراري أن من صفر إلى 60 مرة
أقل من ثلاث ثوانٍ بقليل ،
لكن الحكم على فيراري بثلاثمائة ألف
دولار من خلال الأرقام
يشبه الحكم على سكوتش يبلغ من العمر 12 عامًا من
خلال محتواه الكحولي
أنه يخطئ النقطة التي يصعب
وصف ما يجعل فيراري
أفضل كلمة يمكن أن أتوصل إليها هي
البراعة
، صوت المحرك يستحق روسيني ،
هدير V8 مغطى بشواحن توربينية طنين
عندما تضغط على الغاز
مع فتح الجزء العلوي من الصوت
أفضل شخصيًا.
من الأسطح الصلبة
ولكن هذه السيارة تحتوي على الأقل على
خطوط لطيفة عندما يكون السقف أعلى
، تشعر الشركة بالاستجابة والبديهية ،
يكون ناقل الحركة الأوتوماتيكي سلسًا
وسريع التوجيه أثناء القيادة  يوفر eel إحساسًا رائعًا
بالطريق ولكن دون الشعور
بالقسوة ،
فهذه سيارة أداء متخصصة ،
لذا فهناك بعض
المتاعب
التي تحتوي على Apple carplay على سبيل المثال ، لكنها تظهر
على الشاشة الصغيرة الأصغر
التي رأيتها على الإطلاق إذا كانت جميع السيارات الإيطالية الخارقة
تبدو متشابهة
أنت حقًا لا تتم مقارنتهم
بسيارة لامبورغيني ، على سبيل المثال سيارة فيراري مثل
هذه توفر لمسة أقل
عدوانية وظلًا أكثر دقة
، لا تزال سيارة فيراري الجيدة واحدة من
أفضل الأعمال الفنية
في إيطاليا في هذه السيارة التي يمكنك الاستمتاع بها في الهواء الطلق